um you know the society is is neutral on
the bill
um and in terms of fairness i think
that's a
philosophical or political question and
not really one that
uh that we're looking to take a position
on thank you
okay i agree i i i would
um just add that if you
if um if the bill
is amended to exclude um
or to disallow deductions
that's really more confusing for that's
going to be more confusing for
taxpayers than just not passing the bill
altogether
in my opinion um i mean either way what
what you know it it's just a way to
um to make the
ppp loan proceeds taxable you know
whether you
included his income or disallowed the
deductions
it's the same it's the same result the
the
forgiven amount becomes a taxable
cost to the business and i think
the disallowance of the expenses is a
more confusing
um avenue to do that
because um it's much less clear what the
timing
should be of that um
[Music]
recognition of the disallowed should it
go back to the 2020
year when the expenses were um
paid for or does that disallowance
happen
in the year that the um loan is forgiven
you know we'd need more guidance i think
to
for things to be clear so again we
you know we're neutral on the bill um
and so i don't think i want to get into
the fairness
question but i think it's always
important to
try to um at least keep things as
clear and simple as possible um
no matter what the you know what the
ultimate result ends up being
well thank you for that that's very
helpful okay uh before i go to the next
question
um kyle
and kevin do you represent the society
and did you take a vote that you'd be
neutral on this bill
or is that your own ferns
we we don't didn't take a a vote as a
society we
as a society we've um it's our policy
not to advocate one way or the other
for you know for tax
increases or tax decreases we're
you know what we're trying to do and
what our mission is is to
um help explain how
um different changes in tax law um
you know impact uh taxpayers
and also you know if we do advocate for
anything as i just said we advocate for
clarity um and to
as much as possible simplicity to um
so that it's easy for taxpayers to
comply
and it's clear as to what the rules are
but
um you know we're not we don't as a
matter of policy and
i mean this has been voted on in general
not specific to every time we
talk about something but um you know we
we don't advocate
for increases in taxes decreases in
taxes
um or you know new taxes
you know we're we're not going to
advocate one way or the other for that
it's
it's just the reporting and compliance
that we advocate for
um you know being as clear as possible
for our clients what you said is
it's much clearer to your clients
and yourselves if uh senator
bill three does not pass
because their client would get the ppp
loans
and then they could and if they use it
for what
they apply for they're not going to pay
any taxes because
it's all deducted
is that correct
yeah i i think the you know the
amendment
that's been proposed to sp3
confusion to the timing of when those
expenses
don't get deducted and
i mean right so um
if if you're going to amend sb3
for that it would be simpler just to not
pass it at all and allow the current law
that's in place that the dra has already
issued guidance on
um to stand because we at this point we
understand
the you know we understand how that
is gonna and we're at a point where uh
it could be the particle when
maybe trying to say you gotta forget
it and then if that's the case
in order to be balanced but we'd have to
say
for those that believe it this way is
that
then you can't deduct the expenses if
they
go to the way of the political winds
but anyway we'll go to the next question
miss
ribson a major yes i have to leave in 10
minutes could i ask a question that i
think is clarifying before i go
i sure can represent elementary thank
you very much
on i don't
thinking about the water's edge
on for on mr
hayfield on do you have any idea
on whether the subsidiaries of the
larger businesses
on were able to qualify
for ppp loans on their own
i've seen some indication of that
looking through who got a ppp loan in
lebanon but
i'm not sure how whether that they were
very small
people those and they probably didn't
get good advice
do you have any idea what the advice
would be on that
uh well i do think i i is your
if your question is do um with
subsidiaries of those larger
water's edge groups qualify for ppp and
did some of them receive them i
i think the answer is yes in certain
circumstances i think
there was um
you know the general rule that
businesses over i think 300 employees
um could not apply or qualify for ppp
there were exceptions to that and i
think
some of those exceptions depended on the
industry so
i believe restaurants and and some
hospitality businesses
could qualify based on their
subsidiaries
you know situation and not not not have
to
sort of look at the larger group
um that they belong to
does that answer your question so i
think so yes i believe some
probably did qualify but and some didn't
um yeah
okay representative spellsbury
uh yes i think it's been very very
interesting
commentary so far and
i by the way do not in any way disagree
with the notion that just
failing to pass sp3 it might be a
simpler and more direct route
my concern is that if there is a
political will to csv3
go forward that the amendment may be
necessary and
did i hear you correctly to agree in
your comment uh
i believe to um representative ames
representative major that it is
essentially true that
all uh ppp loans
must be offset by qualified deductions
in order to be forgiven
yes um so if in order to qualify for
forgiveness
they have to have used the loan proceeds
for
the various types of expenses that were
allowed under the program
most of those being wages but there were
some other expenses that were also
qualified and so then do you agree that
the
the um necessary consequence of that is
that that portion
of their um revenue
attributable to the ppp loan uh
cannot on that be subject to ppt tax
i'm sorry i i guess i'm kevin i don't
know if you had
no i'm not sure i understand the
question but to the extent of the ppp
i'm glad to rephrase it
all right well if i can offer a response
which may be the answer that
ppp funds a big piece of that were to be
used for wages and in some cases
it was all used for wages so to the
extent that wages were paid with ppp
funds those wages will be included in
the bet
calculation now if
the the issue is that
the sb3 is passed without an amendment
and that
it follows essentially the irs
guidelines
the income would not be taxable but the
deductions for payroll would still be
allowed
those deductions for payroll would still
be included in the bet calculation
for the new hampshire return does that
answer your question
different perhaps but helpful i i i
think you're confirming that there is a
b
e t uh impact on uh
from from payroll um but
uh i guess i'm just asking you to
confirm
that there that that to the extent that
uh
ppp loans are forgiven as a result of
having been used for qualified expenses
that particular revenue is not
going to generate any tax under rppt
i mean if sp3 is passed you mean
i mean even if sp3 is not passed i mean
if that's
if if if new hampshire law stays the way
it is
and forgiven ppp is uh
therefore included in taxable income it
will be entirely
offset by the expenses for which it was
used
the the expenses for which it was used
will be included as deductions on the
return
yes that's right okay
so there's no net text effect uh
if i may uh chairman major i had another
question
uh so you know in our search
for uh for evidence and data we of
course i have to rely heavily on
anecdote
and the problem with anecdote is it's
spotty uh you don't know how well
reinforced it is but i'm thinking of
several
uh business owners who i know well here
in town
with whom i've had conversation on this
topic
consistently since march 2020
and i i just wonder if i can just
describe those two situations very
briefly
whether you find them to be
representative or aberrations
in one case i'm talking about the owner
of a moving company
and the other case i'm talking about the
owner of a glass company
uh both of them of course were filled
with fear
uh when the government imposed uh
limitations came about and
uh uh things temporarily took
a nosedive for their businesses in march
and april
uh but by may particularly june july
things started to look differently
and uh they both would have predicted
severe impacts but as it turns out they
both did extraordinarily well
in 2020. in the case of the glass
company they weren't in
installing showers so much but they were
busy all over the place installing
plexiglass dividers in schools and
elsewhere
and in the case of the moving company
virtually nobody moved for a couple of
months
and then they saw a surge like they'd
never seen before and broke all their
records in the second half of the year
so i just i think if we were
sitting here uh 12 to 14 months ago
using our crystal ball we would have
drawn very different conclusions about
who would be winners and who would be
losers
there would have been a temptation to
assume there were no winners
and as things turned out i think maybe
an awful lot of surprises have occurred
in your practice and just
gazing across your clientele do you see
many similar situations or you think
that
these were aberrations
um i i have seen some of
those situations um
and then i've i've also seen um some
many uh clients who who
did um struggle and were negatively
impacted for the entire
year um you know for
and it really just depends on the
business who their customers were
and how their customers were impacted
and sort of how that trickled down to
them but yeah i
i have seen stories like you've
described and
i've seen um many stories
of uh sort of the opposite impact as
well
um it's you know pretty diverse in
terms of what we've seen
i would agree with carl it's pretty
diverse
so basically the conclusion is there's
no pattern
nothing i can point to
thank you very much okay
murphy thank you mr chairman and uh
thanks to our guests for joining us and
i
actually was asking the question that
representative spillsbury just brought
up
in my mind given that the cares act and
the ppp
funds were meant to help employees
stay afloat and employees get paid
pay for health benefits pay for
retirement benefits and wages
and given that you both have said that
your
clientele is not the water's edge of the
large corporations
it probably is even more appropriate for
the question that representative
spillsbury asked because it gives us a
flavor of the state
and so i was thinking about the various
businesses you have the business that
took ppe dollars and regardless of how
they
invested it or used it they folded and
declared bankruptcy they had no business
profits tax to speak
of you then have a company that changed
their way
uh received the ppe uh monies
uh changed their model perhaps and
perhaps broke even or had minimal profit
and therefore
not necessarily impacted with the
business profits tax and then you have
the other group that um representative
spillsbury talked about and
i'm trying to just to get a handle in
you on your in your experiences and in
your practices
there's another group that you know made
really
um a significant profit out of the covet
you know whether they were
they changed a business model they were
putting up plexiglas or whatever that
might be
but actually do have had a significant
profit and did take ppp
dollars do you have a sense and i'm just
trying to get a sense of
um percentages in your practices how
would those three groups
break down is the group that made a
significant profit
and impacted with the bpp
um attacks uh is that a large number or
just a sense i know you don't have an
exact number but where do you think
those three buckets lie
um yeah i guess it would be really hard
i would just be guessing um
so i yeah i don't know
yeah i haven't done any sort of review
of that nature
are you impressed with a significant
number of uh businesses that have
changed their model and have had a
significant um
increase in the profit margin of the
businesses as a result of coving
i can't say that i can again i haven't
looked at that particular
ratio to determine if profit margins are
up for
and and if and if so what what
percentage of my clients that represents
okay i mean there's there there are some
absolutely
thank you
representative romney thank you mr chair
um one thing that came up in our
hearings was
a discussion of the main street program
which took some of the 1.8 billion that
the state got
and used it for a similar state-driven
program
uh i'm just curious and my our
understanding is that
uh there's uh this per
this is totally different and that
there'd be no forgiveness of
of uh of the revenue uh or the
the of the uh of the loan i don't even
know i think it was created as a loan
program i'm not even sure
but if any of your clients mention the
main street program to you
or whether they want to see
some kind of a similar thing done with
those revenues as not being taxable
well i mean in terms of of businesses
that receive them
i'm sure any business owner would be
happy not to have to pay tax on them
um and you know in getting banks
to the kind of the original question
when this all started is
in terms of the extensions and things my
firm at least has
for for any client unless there's a
clear indication that they're going to
have to pay the main street relief funds
those funds were included in 2020
even though it was presumed
even though there may be a small chance
they can't have to pay it back and so
that income is included in the 2020
estimates for the extensions
but i'm i can only imagine that
businesses would
be happy to see that the main street
funds are included with the non-taxation
of ppp funds if that happens
all right thank you
any further questions from the committee
members
i've seen and both
kevin and carl and teresa
thank you very much for coming in
and uh helping us understand this
situation we
still have a ways to go and and good
luck to you representative
and to all of you thank you for
including us representative
right before you go
i gotta and i thank every member
got a email from a
cpa organization
and it looks like they're taking a stand
you know
of many cpa organizations that are
taking a stand
one way or the other relative to senate
bill three
um i'm i'm not aware of
i'm not aware i i don't know no no
no do you have the do you have the
specific organization name
um yeah i've got a
okay so there's specific firms not
necessarily the cpa society
yeah that's right this one's amazing
rich professional association
and it just came in this morning i guess
this morning i i read it once and i oh
my god
and i'm gonna have to read that slowly
again yeah it's it's tense
i was surprised i would have thought
that
most cpas would be neutral but
but you know you don't know of many uh
cpas that are
out there but i don't i don't know how
many more of these letters we're going
to get from cpa
groups representative major
um i think robin abbott is on uh
listening to this
and she may be able to give some light
if maceman rich has contacted the
society about
a position to my knowledge we haven't
heard from anyone
any individual society asking for
position we've heard from a lot of
individual society excuse me uh
individual firms
asking what the outcome is of senate
bill 3 and it's been more
for clarification how to treat um
treat the the grant or loan um
in in the tax returns but uh robin may
be able to say if
others have contacted her out of
position but to my knowledge
um we've really been hearing mainly from
firms of
have you all made a decision okay
i notice in the uh attendees
there's a nhs cpa is that a firm or an
organization
that would be robin abbott the executive
director of the new hampshire society of
cpas
would she be willing to join us
just promoted her you
uh robin i am here can you hear me
yes were you able to listen to the
discussion there i did
listen to the whole discussion and thank
you very much for having us on today
um i missed the last maybe 10 seconds of
your comments but i
theresa summed it up very nicely as well
as carl and
kevin so i really want to thank them for
being present they are they are stellar
in what they do and which is why they
represent our tax committee
but to your point um i would say there
are no specific firms that have reached
out to us with the position
however many have shown quite
a great deal of interest on which they
this was going so that they could advise
their clients
because their clients have been very
stressed about this situation in
particular
the one organization i would say that
does take a stand that you may know of
is a national organization called the
american institute
of certified public accountants that's
the aicpa
so many of you have probably heard of
them before
they tend to take a more national
legislative stance
and oftentimes will trickle down their
guidance to us
whether or not we use that is really up
to the society and and our board and our
members
and and carl said it perfectly um as did
kevin as we are neutral on bills but
what we try to do is educate our members
and educate the legislators as far as
you know what both sides are
or are doing so i hope that answers your
question
uh yes it does thank you uh does the
committee
have any further questions to ask of
this distinguished
group of people representative major
representative tudor here
did did i hear um you talk about a straw
poll in the beginning of this that i
missed that or
were you going to tell us about a straw
poll i'd be happy to tell you it was it
was really just kind of a soft pull to
some of my more active members as far as
what their sentiment was on sb3
and many who have had interest in this
from the beginning
um and i would say you know carl summed
it up perfectly
most cpas are really
participating in extensions with their
clients or
if they aren't they are paying a portion
of of what they expect as the ppp
with with a bit of um you know
uncomfortableness i i
would say what i hear mostly is that
most of our members
and again we do not take a stand but
most of our members are in support of
sb3 we're one of the only states that is
sort of taxing this money so
kind of has an icky feel to it when when
and i understand our tax structure is
very different from other states
around the country including in new
england but what we've sort of heard is
that
people are feeling sort of not so great
about being taxed on sort of this found
money
um but again understanding our tax
structure
is different um you know we're doing
what we have to do but i will say this
and and to credit carl and kevin for
being here today
when there was that irx extension on the
17th and they had the deadline on the
15th
this has probably been one of the worst
years
by far for members that they have ever
experienced i mean i'm getting calls on
a routine basis of
yep that's it i'm done i'm hanging up my
for sale sign
i'm good i'm not doing this anymore it's
been really challenging
so if there's any way that you can make
the practitioners and their
clients lives a little bit clearer a
little easier
that would go a long way right and clear
and easier doesn't mean you're taking a
stand
exactly does not
all right any uh further questions
saying thank you very much for appearing
with us today you're welcome thank you
thank you and so committee member
why don't we just take a quick couple
minute break
and then we'll go to the next issue
so
again
you
this
this is not back yet
do you need help figuring out the
the numbers for josh
representative major representative ober
here
uh yes rumor
has it that sb3 is going to be put into
the budget
by the senate rumor has it
the senate does what it wants to do
wow all right uh
chris yes rooster major i'm here
okay good uh i think we can get started
and but having chris do
we have on our revenues
we have four revenues that uh
money is taken from it such as
going to dhhs l chip
affordable housing and likewise
and chris is going to talk about these
you get committee members especially
those that have
come on in the last few years uh
a history of how this happened and
and what it does
so you're all set chris all right thank
you for major
um so the reason that i'm here today to
talk about this if if some of you were
on the call i think
two meetings ago and i brought up the
liquor commission there was a
potential for a transfer of liquor funds
over to
department of health and human services
for the new hampshire granite advantage
program
um and and we didn't know the amount we
still don't know the amount
and then the members of the committee
were asking you know what other programs
do we see money come in on a cash basis
that then is moved to uh
a restricted or a certain purpose
instead of going into the unrestricted
general fund and i named four that you
know in addition to that i named three
others that i was aware of
um as a follow-up repsome spillsbury
reached out to me to get a little bit
more information
um you know kind of why this occurred
and some of the history and i had done
some work for him which he then asked
represent major just suggesting maybe i
should talk to the committee
in total and kind of go over some of
these funds and how they occurred and
and where we are today with them so that
that's what i'm going to do at a kind of
a high level i'm going to share my
screen
and it's just going to be it's a
narrative of the different programs
basically law or chapter law but i'll
talk through kind of how we got to that
point
oh well i can't share my screen
it's disabled right now but that's i'm
going to start with the l chip program
johnny janine i just changed those
settings chris sorry about that
oh that's okay thank you jen
so you should see uh l chip and some
yellow highlights so
so the lchip program is the landing
community heritage investment program
it's a
program that matches local or non-profit
funds to conserve property buildings
throughout the state it's a competitive
program
it's something that you know started
back in the early 2000s and
for from 2002 to 2008
the legislature would put appropriations
in the budget to fund
l-chip and what would typically occur is
there'd be an appropriation for a
certain
amount through the budget process it
would be reduced or removed in
total so the program didn't have the
seed
money to do what it was charged to do
sometimes there was other efforts to add
money in separate bills and those
wouldn't
survive so there was lots of discussion
in the legislative body and
and interested groups to try to come up
with a dedicated
funding mechanism for the l-chip program
and what was decided is that a surcharge
on
certain um documents that the
register of deed register of deeds
processes and
in this sheet before you can see
roman 2 the highlighted part an
additional charge of 25
shall be assessed so that was the amount
that was agreed up to
um in 2008 session
to fund the l-chip program and then what
occurred with that is they basically
said
register of deed you shall collect this
and remit it back to the state of new
hampshire
basically using the same mechanism that
the rep money comes to the state of new
hampshire
and it would go to the dra who would
then peel off or
or account for the rep the surcharge
related to the l-chip program
and then that would be used to pay the
lchip program
through treasury if you were to look at
the operating budget you will find
in the treasury's operating budget
there's a an accounting unit that is for
lchip
so the treasury actually cuts a check to
l-chip at the
start of each fiscal year
there's an estimated budget on what they
think they might gain in revenue
and if they don't gain that then they
don't get all the the appropriation
if they get more than what they've
estimated they're able to come through
fiscal
through treasury to accept the
additional revenue which they've done
the last few years
so so it is money that comes in and
on a monthly basis there's an adjustment
made
to remove it from the the cash
and put it where it belongs with
treasury to go to l-chip
right now they're estimating about five
million dollars a year that that is
removed as a result of the surcharge so
it's not the ret
tax that that is doing this it's it's a
separate surcharge
um but it just comes in in the door kind
of on the back of the ret tax as it's
because back when they put this together
there was a lot of discussion about
creating more work at the local level
in terms of collecting and remitting um
revenue back to the state so that's the
l chip i mean if anybody has any
questions
um any questions i see representative
yes thanks chris um so when we do our
revenue
estimates we're not including that 25
no no um usually that's kind of it's
backed out so that
when you get to the end of the year you
know there's
throughout the every month that's backed
out of the the uh
cash number right so at the end of the
year there's an adjustment made
you've heard about all these adjustments
that occur at the end of the year
so when you get your total at the end
you know that the
five million you know it's been three to
five million a year
um is not included in your base number
okay so and i guess one other oh sorry
go ahead
okay i'm just wondering does that get
budgeted somewhere that five million or
is that just
money that comes into that fund so
that's budgeted in the treasury's
uh operating budget i get it okay so
it's been in there for for a number of
years
um and it continues to be there
for i think for a number of reasons i
think one of them is so that um
people who are interested in what's
going on with the lg program can
actually see there's an appropriation
that goes to that
to that program um one thing that did
occur
when when they this surcharge was put in
place
the first few um budget cycles
the l-chip program still didn't get 100
of the revenue generated the legislature
would put language in
um house bill 2 or or a version of the
op
of the trailer bill to redirect um
some of that revenue back to the general
fund these were years when
we were going through the great
recession or coming out of the great
recession
um so you may have heard of you know if
you've been around at all you've heard
the term uh rating dedicated funds you
know rate on the fund
and and so that was was occurring and
there was efforts by
the supporters of the lchip program and
other dedicated funds to
um ask the legislature to stop doing
that so that
since about 2017 i think
there's been no adjustment that
everything has gone to the lchip program
and when we get the periodic reports
from the department
of bigger services it'll tell us like
a recent one says um l chip
approximately five hundred thousand
dollars which would be
which will come out of re tt on the 16th
of the month
yep once yeah so
so there's an accounting for it but
depending on when you're looking at a
report it still may be in the cache
so that so it gets a little confusing
but it is adjusted out
and again when you're doing your
estimates in the committee
that's been accounted for
so the next is the uh the school
building aid debt service
that comes out of the meals and rooms
tax so again similar to
tourette there's a note typically on
some of the um reports that you get that
says
uh by the certain day of the month the
the amount going to the building a debt
service will be
um will be removed from from the the
numbers
so what occurred here is back in 2008
well 2009 10 and 11 so so those
fiscal years but starting in 2008
session year
there was concerns on with the recession
just getting
started a concern on meeting the promise
to the communities that had borrowed
money to build school buildings and the
state's school building aid
program where they match a percentage i
think it's up to like 20
of of the cost of the debt service for
these
buildings at that time um you know
building aid it was a significant amount
of the budget it was about 40 million
dollars a year
and decisions had to be made on how do
we fund some of these things we don't
have the revenue to support it
so back in 2009 during um this was
what i'm showing you is the language
that's contained in chapter 144 laws of
2009 that was house bill 2 at the time
you're going to see that a number of
things occurred with the meals and rooms
tax at that time
it went from eight percent to nine
percent so that's the first part of this
you're going to see there was a section
put in that said
you're going to take the amount
necessary
so the yellow bold here to pay the
interest on the
bonds and notes that were authorized in
the 198 colon 15a relates to the school
building aid
debt as well as the amount of 3.15
percent
that would go to the former dread travel
and tourism
um that number came up earlier this uh
with this committee
about a month ago six weeks ago there
was some question about this number
being suspended in the budget
and that is correct so instead of
the budget reflecting 3.15 percent of
the meals and rooms collected it's
something slightly
less than that there's still over 17
million dollars over the biennium going
to travel and tourism but
the governor and the house proposal is
slightly different than what 3.15 would
equal
and as i said the the school building
aid during that period
in 2009 it was going to be a 40 million
appropriation
and then in 10 and 11 it was just under
45 million and then 46.2 million
so you're paying on this debt service
out to 2030.
so until that point unless something
changes you'll see
an amount um taken off every month
to pay this uh bond debt service related
to the bonds for school building aid
the amount is the amount is going down
now so the the high point or the most
that was ever paid in a particular year
was about 14 million
it's down to about 8 million now a year
and it'll continue to trickle down as we
get closer to the end
again it was it was a decision made at a
time when revenues were
lower than anticipated um there was no
projection to go forward but the state
wanted to to continue to meet that
obligation or promise it had made to the
schools
and the communities related to the
school building aid
so that's all i really had to say on
that and i can move to the next thing
unless there's a question
it doesn't seem to be any questions go
ahead all right
i just raised my hand norm
[Music]
i just happened to notice on the in the
first page of that last
two slides that campsites were to be
taxed and that that didn't last very
long now did it
no no that's why i didn't bring it up
i couldn't resist um i know that was
ripped
very quickly and and i guess i should
say the
part of the reason i show you that that
there was an increase in the meals in
rooms tax rate
that was part of the debate for
justifying that it was okay
to at least for the the uh biennium they
were budgeting for the 10 and 11
biennium
that increase would have allowed for
enough money to cover the debt service
associated with the school bonding aid
skill school building aid bonding debt
service so
um that that was the reason i showed it
there it wasn't to create any other
discussion
the next and the more recent um
one that is that you guys are hearing
about is the liquor fund transfer
related to the new hampshire granite
advantage
so as many um as many people know back
in 2014
the um
there was changes to to medicaid and
health insurance through
through uh um
the uh yeah why is it slipping me
that basically president obama's changed
to health care
and one of the changes was to allow for
an expansion to medicaid
and there was a lot of discussion a lot
of concern in the state
as in many states about this expansion
and the costs associated with it when it
was first
proposed the federal government was
paying 100 percent of that expanded
expansion cost or the medicaid
cost associated with that and then over
the years it was going to come down
from 100 percent to where we are today
at 90 percent
um so there was concerns that and it was
um kind of likened to the idea of uh uh
special ed funding that the feds had
always promised that would be provided
to states and
and there was feelings that they've
never fully
lived up to that promise that they would
do the same thing with the
federal dollars associated with the
medicaid expansion
so the legislature passed bills to
get it started and then again in 2018
because of some changes with the funding
mix
re-authorize it as the new hampshire
granite advantage health care
program and then created a trust fund
and one of the things in the trust fund
that was negotiated at a time and has
been a focus is that
no state general fund shall be deposited
into the fund
so the medicaid expansion program
should continue forward without any
general funds that was very important
and something that's remained in statute
since then
but as we've gotten um increased in the
numbers of people participating in the
program
along with the um funding
mix being more the state providing a
greater share
there was some concerns that
there's not enough money coming in
through the health insurance premium
or any other way that is covering the
full
cost between the 90 percent the federal
government pays for in the 10 percent
that the state would be responsible for
so in the in the law there's there's a
section it's a roman
six and you're going to see the
highlighted piece if you were to remove
the highlighted piece that was that's
what was there
up until 2019. so basically read the
commission accordance with the most
current available information
shall be responsible for determining
quarterly commencing no later than
december 31 2018
whether there is sufficient funding in
the fund to cover projected program
costs for the non-federal share
for the next six month period if at any
time the commissioner
determines that a pr projected shortfall
exists
he or she will terminate the program in
accordance with the federally approved
terms
and conditions issued by cmc
so prior to the liquor commission aspect
being added that was the concern
and if that language wasn't in there
earlier this year
health and human services would have had
to abide if
there had been no change would have had
to abide by this language and start to
terminate
or close down the the medicaid expanded
program because of a
lack of funding so one way to
address this was to use the liquor
commission fund
and the suggestion is it's not
at this point it's not general funds so
you've you've still abided by the
no use of general funds but because of
the uncertainty and knowing
what kind of shortfall you're going to
have in the out years
they've allowed for an open
appropriation and for the amount
necessary to be transferred from the
liquor commission fund
and then there's a statement that um you
know if there's then if there's no
if there's insufficient funds from the
liquor fund
then they shall at that point start the
process to close or
re um eliminate the program
so that's that's how that occurred and
that's the reason it's occurred is that
the
the legislature a couple years ago was
looking for
a a mechanism that could fund the
program if there was a shortfall
without um assigning general funds to it
and then the last one and probably the
most recent one
that you've seen is the affordable
housing affordable housing is not a new
issue in the state of new hampshire it's
been discussed uh
you know for over 10 years now in
various venues
if you were to do a simple search in in
the
bill search function in on the website
um you're going to see bills going back
you know it's like i said 10 years or
more for study committees
commissions bills that would have
provided
capital appropriations to do affordable
housing
incentives for your municipalities and
and
local governments to set up affordable
housing funds
and in the last few years you've heard a
lot of discussion about workforce and
the inability
for the workforce to find housing which
is
creating some challenges for businesses
that want to grow or expand or move into
the area
so this last budget session it was felt
that
you know this is probably the right time
to
dedicate or restrict five million
dollars a year that comes in through the
real estate um
transfer tax to to go into
the affordable housing fund and and then
the housing finance authority is
responsible for that fund
and they would um be the group um making
it available to the communities and the
places and businesses that that would be
eligible for it
so you saw that hit the first time back
in september
of this f20 september 20
and uh it caused a lot of questions at
that time because as you saw a reduction
of
a comment about a reduction of 5 million
dollars for the the
housing finance authority for the
affordable housing
in the revenue focus that came out after
that month
so i think you know the reason i'm i'm
talking about this is just to provide
you a little bit of a
history that on why some of these
actions occurred it's
many times it's not as a result of oh
today i think it's a good idea that i
take money and restrict it from this
fund for a purpose that
is fairly newly discussed you most of
these have
had discussions for a number of
legislative sessions
and there's been a number of different
um efforts to find a way to
have a steady revenue stream for them
so so those are the four that you know
stuck out and that we
you know i kind of talked about at a
high level the other day
and this is just a little bit lower but
still at a high level
so that's all i have well thank you
chris
and with this mechanism if you continue
uh dedicating
these revenue streams to specific
items then there'd be a lot less general
funds that can be utilized to support
the rest of the
budget and it's a kind of short search
short circuits the regular budget
process
i i think reps of almighty jumped off
the call for she had a conflict with
another meeting but if i think she was
on the call
she would probably um i'm going to
suggest that she would make a comment
about the whole dedicated fund
process where that you know that's
in some ways this is a is like that you
know it's it's restricting a certain
revenue
or a piece of a certain revenue for a
purpose the dedicated funds
are truly that where the revenue doesn't
come into the
um the collections of the general fund
or the highway fund or
that we see on in the revenue focus but
they're they go directly to those funds
the four that i just shared with you are
slightly different in that they do kind
of pass through the
the collection of the revenue that that
you see in the revenue focus but and
then they're deposited to a
this particular place representative has
his hand up reps of major
yeah i just want to ask chris if you can
send us this uh
slide pack yep yep i'll do that
all right well thank you very much chris
you all appreciate it
you're welcome and uh
janine thank you
i've asked the dre to be present
any update
on
the revenues
lost due to senate bill 3 and they
emailed you the latest estimate but
if they could bring in carolyn and
melissa
mr chair uh representative gomarlo cut
out so i've just promoted
carolyn melissa and devin oh thank you
good morning representatives good
morning
so carolyn could you give us an update
of where you are
on uh senate bill three
and its effect on revenues yeah so
um what you saw this morning was our
analysis
of the um
the fiscal impact assuming that all
ppp loans were issued
by the end of the month um that is a
fiscal impact of just under 100 million
dollars
and i saw a news article come across my
screen this morning that i didn't have
an opportunity to open up that said
that as of today they have exhausted the
full appropriation
for ppp so i think that is a good final
um impact for you folks to use
i saw the same thing this morning
um right now uh you know where
where do we go from here i think the
department
is trying to look at some possible
methodologies
for helping you understand the
fiscal year impact of
our analysis you know we we've presented
it as a total but not
broken it up by fiscal year
but certainly we would expect it to
happen across
many fiscal years um representative ames
had forwarded the california analysis
and we're actually trying to do some
digging to see if we can speak with
someone
from california to see how they broke
their analysis up by fiscal year
for pp um
for their ppp bill yeah
and the california on their analysis
they
they said it's gonna cost them six point
two billion dollars uh by forgiving the
loan
but i have no idea what their total
revenue is on
corporate taxes agreed and i also noted
when i
pulled up that bill it was a bit more
comprehensive than ours
it also included the impact
for certain federal treatment of
eidl loans which is not contained
without within our sb3
so we'll have to carefully sort of uh
evaluate whether
the california methodology works for our
bill um but we are looking into that
excuse me
yeah uh that's great i'm glad you're
looking at that um
the other another difference for
california is that they've
excluded publicly traded
companies and i don't know what that
the dimensions of that would be but i
don't think we could do that in new
hampshire
even if we wanted to um and then there's
a 25
000 rule that they've got in there
so firms that have
who's i can't remember how it works but
there's a 25
000 um bar
in terms of revenues
maybe you can explain it i can't quite
put it together i think it's the 25
decline 2020 over 19.
thank you
and i think the only other thing that i
would add is i think
the testimony that you heard
from the cpas today was very helpful
um i think that we often don't have the
you know the very granular taxpayer
perspective on these things because
we're not return preparers
um so i think it's definitely helpful to
understand what they're seeing
in the field to know that really there's
a spectrum
of treatments that taxpayers have
adopted
and certainly we are seeing
currently and melissa can jump in with
the stats if she wants to
but we are seeing very high levels of
um extensions this year and
i think that means that we're going to
have
really limited information about what
taxpayers have done on their 2020
returns until such time as those
extended returns are in fact
filed what we have now for data is just
so limited that it's not particularly
useful
if i may comment uh
go ahead yeah um
yeah so the extensions are um
correct me if i'm wrong but the amount
of money
um paid with uh for extensions
is is unprecedented in size
and um and yet it's a black hole for you
you don't
all you have is a number is that correct
that's exactly right melissa do you have
the exact stats
sure melissa allen senior financial
analyst for the department
um yeah everything you're saying
representative ames is completely
accurate so extensions this month
were 131.5 million that is we have a
10-year trend on the
estimate analysis and voucher analysis
that we send out to you and that is by
far the highest we have
ever seen it's 195 percent above fiscal
year 20
however i caution you to compare it to
fiscal year 20 because we do know that
the federal due date
and state new hampshire due date in
fiscal year 20 was extended to june
um for new hampshire and july for
federal but if you do
compare that to fiscal year 19 it's
about 50
or 51 million above or 63
above 2019 so a very significant
um increase in dollars
and counts for sure for extensions
representative thank you mr chairman um
i i thought that the the question that
uh representative ames asked
yesterday during our discussion about
timing
um it posed potential conundrums that we
hadn't thought about and i certainly
wasn't in a position to uh uh to clarify
so both of the accountants who
spoke to us this morning uh alluded to
that same concern
uh when they were talking about the
relative merits
of amending
sb3 versus just not passing it
and it it seemed to me when they were
saying that
that uh the discrepancies in timing
actually highlight
a fundamental flaw in
the intent of sb3 and that is
if it's already true
that qualifying for loan forgiveness
requires deploying
the funds for qualified expenses they've
already been offset
uh what we're doing here if we also
allow
the deductions to be taken is we're
de-linking
uh the expenses from the source of funds
and this de-linking this this allowing
expenses that were already used that
were already paid for with one set of
funds
to be deducted against another set of
revenue
is exacerbating the timing problem
was there i yeah i agree and um i was
there
a question or were you just asking if i
agreed with that
i suppose i'm asking if you agree but i
i i guess the point is that if the
amendment
the purpose of the amendment to sp3 is
in effect to neutralize the impact of
sb3 is it probably
not correct that the accountant's
observation
is it might be better to just not pass
sb3
because that would be the less
complicated route
yes i agree that um
that it would certainly
be a complication to taxpayers relative
to the timing of the disallowed expenses
um and i think that exists
potentially as well with
sb3 as proposed in both scenarios i
think
what you're looking at is the
possibility of
a large number of amended 2020 returns
regardless of what form senate bill 3
ultimately takes but as
you can certainly imagine
an amended return that results in a
reduced
tax liability feels a bit different to a
taxpayer
than an amended return that results in
an increased
liability so i think
for planning purposes one is probably
more palatable to a taxpayer than the
other
thank you good observation
rep senator browning that leads us to
the question of
the same conversation here of uh whether
we amend or
uh if we amend
is it is it the same as
just killing the bill in terms of
revenue impact
so if you amend
the the bill concurrent with
representative spillsbury's draft
amendment
i think what you would see is a very
drastic
reduction in the fiscal impact
but there would be
still a small fiscal impact i believe
that the requirement to qualify for
forgiveness was not that 100 percent
be spent on qualified expenses i believe
it was
80 be spent on qualified expenses
and so there would still be potentially
a 20
or less um amount
of what we've currently calculated that
would be a fiscal
impact but it would certainly be
significantly decreased follow up
so what i to take away from what they
were saying uh that the accountants
related to bet
i guess would be a bit different then
with the amendment or or killing the
bill
or amending it there may be some
interaction with the bet that may be a
little different is
what i kind of took away from what they
were saying
yeah i think the direct bet impact
is the same um regardless of
how sp3 makes it out
of committee if it does um the bet
direct impact is um
is the same i believe what carl and
kevin were saying
was that for many taxpayers
they have so much bet credit that
sb3 doesn't really impact their ultimate
tax liability um
and that is actually baked into our
our analysis that you have currently we
we account for those
taxpayers that will not have a bet
or will not have a bpt liability due to
their bet credit
um regardless of what we do
okay thank you
questions can i uh
norm can i know in other hands can i
interject one other thing
uh yes so may 11th is coming upon us
the six days away uh a general question
anybody
has anybody heard including dra of
of the treasury federal treasury coming
up with guidance on the 1.9 trillion
dollars
that does have a bearing on our
discussions i think
and i i i haven't heard any anything uh
has anybody heard anything
i've been looking i haven't seen
anything right we're all waiting for the
guidance
and it's six days away we're not going
to
exact senate bill three on the 11th if
we don't have
more information such as this guidance
right
i'm just just reminding everybody that
that's still hanging out there
thank you yeah
any um questions asked of the dra
if not i want to remind the committee
that
before we get to house bill 565
next week we're going to have an exec
session on tuesday
hopefully we'll exact six of the seven
bills
the one we won't be exacting the senate
bill 3
unless we get additional information
and then on wednesday the 12th
we're going to continue with revenues
and hopefully
we can have somebody come in and i'm
hoping that we have
guidance on the latest stimulus
that would help us
the next thing we want to discuss is
representative romney
has been working with the senate
relative
to house bill 565 which we had passed
and it also appears
in an ominous bill over there so
represent
romney would you explain that yeah so i
touched on it briefly yesterday but i i
since then i did have a conversation
with senator d'alessandro
and with uh representative hill who
chairs the
legislative administration committee
which is where this
is senate bill 100 which is an omnibus
bill
on section four relates to a uh
committee to study charitable gaming
so our our uh representative
and i chatted with representative ames
uh yesterday morning about this as well
uh but now i got a little more detail so
house bill 565 passed out of our
committee which was our version of
of the uh a study committee uh chair
study channel gaming committee
uh passed unanimous out of us that
passed on the floor in consent
whenever the senate the senate passed it
uh but then put it on the table
it's still unclear why they put it on
the table but i could think of some
scenarios why they put it on the table
now in our bill
we just said three members of the house
and two members of the
uh picked by the speaker and two members
of the senate
appointed by the senate president
in the hou and the senate version
they they say two members of the senate
one that comes from finance and one that
comes from ways and means
and then they say in their version they
say three members of the house
one from ways and means one from finance
and then
the other is either or or
other committee appointed by the the
house speaker so
what i suggested to senator d'alessandro
this morning is that you know we have no
problem with the senate picking who they
want to be on their
on the committee uh but
we may want to change what
the makeup on our side is and uh
i said uh i i think
i think it's better that that the
members come all from ways and means
because
on the house side because we're the most
familiar with this
and then per our conversation yesterday
uh representative um
suggested well can we make it at least
one from
the minority party which would probably
happen on its own
uh usually these they usually if it's
three members it'll be two from the
majority party one from the minority
party most committees that i've been on
over the years that's the way it works
but we we could state it that way so
he had no problem senator alessandro
said yeah that's fine but why don't you
make it two and two
so that's another option um
this is not a partisan uh committee
uh at all we're just trying to study all
aspects of charitable gaming
uh so i'm fine with it either way
uh if we if we amend
senate bill uh 100
section part 4 where this resides
um to do to say either
uh two uh two members or three members
from the
ways of means two from the majority
party one from the minority party
or four members of ways of means
to two members that come from the uh
minority party and two to come from the
majority party
so uh i was just trying to get a feel
from the
committee of would anybody object if
uh either way uh on this
okay so and then i i
uh so there's a chant these are omnibus
bills so when i talk to
uh to the uh representative hill
chairs legislative administration he
says that there's about six or seven
commissions or committees
that are there he says there's probably
going to be only one or two that are
going to survive and they're going to
amend out
some of these others so
ours being one that will survive and
then what i'm gonna do i said well i
need to get you an amendment
he says no no i don't do that i'm gonna
be putting an amendment through
just give us the language that you want
for this bill which i'll do
so uh but then he then he was a little
concerned about
and there's reason why we should pass
this and then also you know uh
support and then i asked senator del
santo this morning
i said if we amend this and if
for whatever reason this omnibus bus
bill doesn't make it through the house
floor
uh that you'll be willing to amend the
house bill 565 in the same manner and he
said yeah absolutely so
we're good either way but but
uh representative hill said
you know there could be a reason why he
thought more conspiracy
theory than i did there could be another
reason why they
they tabled it is because they may hang
other bills onto this one and make it a
christmas tree
and i see hey i like to laugh at rick
rich
yes uh so uh
so he says yeah we'll make sure we pass
it so that
you know they can't make both of these
christmas trees
so uh because what happens if they do
that
is it odd it could be that we just get
so frustrated with the senate
that they hung all these other things
that we just veto the whole you know we
we vote no on the floor to the amended
five six 565. so
um that's some of the high intrigue here
does anybody have a problem with what
pat has said i i don't i i
uh i guess i wonder um
i do have a favor between four members
from the house and two members from the
house
not really i'd be honest with you i i
think it'd probably be better
to have the four um that's what i'm
thinking too
about who's gonna show up from the
senate a little more participation on
our side
yeah i agree again it's not a partisan
thing to me it's
it's uh i don't think it is i i think we
need to have more representation there
um to keep the quorum or whatever to
do yeah okay i'm going to have to leave
right at noon so
i'm sad thank you all right are we all
set
okay thank you for your participation
today
and i i plan on having a republican
caucus at 10 o'clock on monday morning
and i'll talk to susan and she'll
be having one too the primary to get us
ready for the executing
of these senate bills on tuesday next
week
yeah and for democrats i'll be sending
out uh susan and i will be sending out a
uh a zoom notice for friday midday i
don't have the exact time
in my head but it's the same time it's
been
as has been stated 11 30 i think
what is that 11 30 yeah
yes um i have a rockingham
subcommittee meeting at 10 do you think
all right 11 i'm sorry do you think
we'll be uh
we'll be done in an hour
i i really don't know but
uh that's that's okay talk to me
separately and we'll work something out
okay
i i have to leave thank you everybody
you're wrong okay bye-bye